I believe that leadership is really a
skill of influence if you look at what
the chokehold is on our business it's
always the leader my number one belief
about leadership is you're a servant
wanna soar get a mentor
what's up believe nation it's evan i
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best tony robbins and
how to master the art of leadership
mentor me tony also if you want to know
what tony has to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link is in the
description below the fact that human
beings our strongest drive is the need
to stay consistent with how we define
ourselves so while you're in this
passionate state that's where you make
decisions so if you want to change your
life my friends you got to change your
physiology and you got to change your
focus
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one master the skill of influence I
believe that leadership is really a
skill of influence is the most important
skill that any human being can master
and I don't think of leadership as a
position I see it as a skill a tool that
all of us have to have in other words
the quality of your life either really
believe comes down to your level of
leadership other people don't have to
follow you to be a leader but you have
to live life on your terms and the first
person you have to influence it yourself
you know whether you're fit or fat you
know whether your kids are out you know
on drugs or not it's who has more
influence the guy in the street corner
or you whether you're fit or fattest can
you influence your own hands your own
body your own mind to do what's
necessary so I think to be able to
influence the thoughts the feelings the
emotions and the actions of another
human being that's what leadership is I
really believe in order influence people
you got to know what already influences
them the mistake that we make is we
don't connect enough to figure out who
this person is and what most of us do is
try to lead other people by influencing
them the way we'd be influenced they try
to influence their kid to clean the room
the way that would make you do it but
even though they're your kid they're
different than you and so they're gonna
do it for a different set of reasons
than what you would do it for you might
have done it because someone told you to
but your kids come all day long that's
not it there has to be something else
it's a sense of freedom they get from it
or a sense of mass just something that's
gonna move them so I always say there
are two things that influence everyone
if you want to be a leader you have to
know how to change other people's states
a person is in a no state a person's in
an angry state persons in a frustrated
state you have to be able to influence
their stake is if you change their state
you're gonna change the result they get
but the second thing you have to
understand is what are people's
blueprints blueprints my shorthand for
what are the values what do they believe
what do they fear I always say to people
that life is found in the dance between
what you desire most and what you fear
most if I want to lead you and support
you I got to know your goals your
desires I don't know what you're scared
about what you're fearful about what
stresses you out and if I understand
that I can communicate in a way that
will inspire you to maximize not only
when I'm here that's management
leadership is on goal
and you've raised your own standard and
you're gonna continue to perform at a
higher level rule number two take
command what makes you a leader is your
ability to make a decision who's with me
on this right and anybody can make the
easy decision right so what makes you a
leader is you can make the tough
decisions and what makes you a leader is
you make the decision what makes you
great leaders you know I may be wrong
but if I have to wait till everything's
resolved nothing's gonna get resolved so
I'm gonna make a decision if I make a
decision and it's wrong I'll find out
quicker than if I sit on the fence while
my life goes by I remember I I've showed
this with maybe a few of you before but
years and years ago when we had the big
Gulf War generals you know Norman
Schwarzkopf friend of mine and passed
away three years ago and I used to bring
him in to talk about leadership and one
of the first times I ever asked him I
said how do you define leadership you
know how do you know what a person's
really lead and he said well they can
make decisions and he said I can
remember when I was he was an assistant
to a to a general and I forgot what the
exact position is but he said he was
responsible for reading all the briefs
and this generals highest generals in
the Army and it was a decision that it
need to be made and had to deal with ten
years of going back and forth with the
Pentagon trying to figure out well if
they're gonna make a go one direction or
another was a gigantic decision that was
gonna affect the way the army was
structured how money was gonna be
divided what resources are gonna go
where and he said they brought it in
this group of twenty people in and they
had this two-hour meeting and everybody
got up and pitched their side of what
they thought was right and at the end
when it was completely done the general
said has everyone said their piece he
said yes he said do this it was plan a
and Plan B whatever it was out of the
three choices the head and everybody
said okay okay general saluted him and
ran off to go implement this thing and
and swartz cop said he was freaking out
because he knew there's no way that
general could have read everything even
he'd read and this was such a complex
piece and there was only two hours and
everybody gave their best but my god
there's so many things to consider and
so he finally he got up enough courage
he said to go the general said general
saluted permission to speak freely
he said he's speak freely he said
general there's so much information here
and there's so much here no one's can
really gonna know for sure how the how
could you just make that decision like
that
he said because someone had to make it
he said because it's been going around
for 10 years back and forth and no one
being able to make a decision he said
what if you're wrong he said if I'm
wrong we'll find out quicker if I'm
right the job will be done next question
right it's like when you're put in
charge take command rule number three
learn to execute it on an airplane
what's the first thing they say if we
get into trouble masks will come down
oxygens there and the first thing you
got to do is put it on your kid right no
why
they literally tell you to put it on
yourself you selfish bastard what's the
deal here right but it's because we
don't take care of ourselves we can't
tear them so for leaders when I was
telling this it's you first it starts
with you and it starts with your
psychology 80% of growing a business if
you look at what the choke hold is on
our business it's always the leader and
80% of that choke hold is the psychology
at 20% the mechanics I mean people in
this room know the mechanics and
strategies beyond what anybody on earth
knows in their category so it's really
about you being in the state where you
execute it's like I always tell people
knowledge is not power it's total BS
knowledge is potential power execution
Trump's knowledge every day of the week
and some of my life is how do you get to
yourself to execute an execution comes
from learning to put yourself in that
right state of it it and rule number
four the last one before a very special
bonus clip is serve my number one belief
about leadership is you're a servant but
here's what I mean here's what I mean
specifically the word hero hero that
isn't the archetype of like men and you
and I I bet it's my is it true that
inside of you you want you wouldn't want
to be the best you want to create the
best share the best do the best is that
is that a metaphor for you in your life
absolutely yeah me too so I think people
in this room tend to have that as their
metaphor so all of us at some level man
or woman wants to be a hero the word
hero if Latin root means servo servo
means servant
it actually means slave the hero why
they're the hero has become the ultimate
servant to something larger than
themselves people and so forth the
person who thinks they're going to lead
by demand or by position can only leave
for a short period of time but the
person who's idea is serving as my
belief is
if you can find a way to take any group
of people and help them to experience
their needs and a richer deeper level
than anyone else then together you guys
can get anything done anything now it
may not work the first time but together
you can get to that point because needs
are ultimately we're after we're not
after the vehicle we think rafter you
want a billion dollars then you get it I
got plenty clients and I will tell you
it is not the end game and so now if
then they go after their second billion
or you think it's getting married and
then you get it you find out it's not
the end game there's certain needs that
have to be there and the ultimate needs
are growing and giving because you only
can feel so good filled up by yourself
so my core belief is I got a serve if I
serve I can lead because I believe
motive does matter if my motive is just
to get you to do something for me
there's a certain amount of power that I
can get to do that if I strategize if I
think if I feel and also if it serves a
greater good even if I don't intend it
if the bumblebee goes to try to get the
nectar it wants it's selfish goal I
believe there's a higher power of the
guys at all and when that bumblebee goes
it doesn't intend to give anything but
pollen sticks to its legs as it goes
about trying to get what it wants that's
how flowers are created I really believe
that everything has a web of connection
if your intent is to serve yourself
you're still going to serve something
more than yourself and you're going to
get a certain amount of insight if your
intent in your motive is to serve
something yourself but also something
more just your kids then I believe you
get a different level of insight and
because you're serving more of what
serves life it's not just me it's me and
my family if you're trying to serve a
community I believe you get a different
level of insight transfer of humanity
you get a different one I get emotional
thinking about this is why I do what I
do so when someone stands up it's not
about business it's not about anything
but about serving them so I will use
abrasive or creative language I'll use
whatever it takes humor stupidity I'll
make fun of myself I'll challenge I'll
do anything to serve that's why I'm here
I don't need to do more but I love to
see
one free and alive and lit up so when
that's your motive no matter how people
perceiving it outside if they're around
you long enough
you can't hide what your real motive is
and they'll see it and they'll feel it
motive does matter if it's to serve
something high it'll be that that
doesn't mean you don't get served too
and in business you got to be served or
I used to do business and I lose money
in the business everybody else was happy
and it was wonderful except I had no
business so it's you know killing the
goose that lays the golden eggs so I've
learned to put that balance in but that
gives me power that's why time
disappears for me because I'm not about
getting some action down I'm about the
outcome now I've got a special bonus
clip from Tony on how to raise your
standards that I think you're gonna
really enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point line any questions
time to move from just watching another
video to actually taking action and if
you're brave leave your replies in the
comments below here we go question
number one what do you need to execute
on this week number two how can you
better serve someone today and number
three how will you practice taking
command
the number one thing that's gonna change
your life the only thing that will
change your life change your business
change your money change your
relationship because you must raise your
standard and I know that sounds boring
stupid basic but it's the truth the only
thing that changes our life long term is
when we raise our standards what does
that mean that sounds so boring and dumb
it means that all of us in life have
things we want we don't get what we want
we get what we have to have remember I
said earlier we all get what we tolerate
in ourselves and other people but when
you're no longer willing to tolerate
something that's when your life changes
the difference in people is their
standards period the difference in
people is their standards period and
what I mean by standards everyone in the
world has a list of things they think
they should do I should lose weight I
should work out I should spend more time
with my kids I should work harder I
should make more calls I should I should
I should I should and then you know what
people don't do their shirts and they
get mad at themselves and they when I
call [ __ ] all over themselves they beat
themself up about it
what changes people is when you should
becomes a must when suddenly the thing
you said should happen has to happen
that's when human beings change it's
like if you want to take the island and
you're the head of the army you want to
take the iron pilot the most powerful
way to take the Islanders burn the boats
because if there's no way to go back
it's amazing what happens when it's a
must to do something versus a should
that's what makes human beings succeed
raise your standard Apple at the pool
it's core value is that we believe that
people your passion can change the way
people not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your it's suppose to mean
if you want to keep learning from Tony
and understand how to create massive
confidence check out the video next to
me I think you're gonna enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
so if you consider yourself to be a
conservative person or a shy person I
know the way you move to some extent I
know the facial expressions the gestures
the way use your body